[Musique]
alors ce matin nous avons tourné la
première cérémonie et c'était après en
avoir qu'on était tout les 13 c'est
chaud chaud d'art mais franchement c'est
mortel
songe à la douceur de vivre ensemble du
molière devant m
[Rires]
[Musique]
bien
logano et oui on va commencer va vous
expliquer le moment willy mois oui
exactement
non mais personne est assise un nom du
monde est debout vêtues alors ça
n'existe pas rarement là la chance et la
joie de partager des scènes avec autant
d'acteurs c'est un truc qui se passe je
pense que souvent au théâtre qu'au
cinéma et en même temps là c'était
encore autre chose qu'on était défi de
tout toutes les filles sont de la même
génération donc c'était très très joyeux
et puis il ya un truc aussi devoir jouer
autant d'actrice quoi de ce face à un
cadeau quoi
[Musique]
mademoiselle vous avez doute passer un
moment privilégié avec marc non pas moi
oui c'est vrai oui bon bah vous avez
tout quasiment passé un moment quasi
privilégié ma dans quelques instants
vous le savez l'une d'entre vous devra
quitter définitivement cette aventure -
cérémonie tu observes vraiment chaque
personnage à son maximum mais elle ne
partira pas seul j'ai de la chance
d'observer pour toutes ces actrices et
acteurs en train d'expérimenter et
d'explorer parlait pas trop juste sur
vous je peux partir à tout moment
ml tu es perdu gigote j'avais déjà
utilisé tout retombe sur toi même
on l'attendait tous parce qu'on sait que
c'est à chaque fois le pilote payne de
d2 chacun de chacun des épisodes parce
que dans l'inconscient collectif on a
tous vu plus ou moins de télé réalité on
sait qu'à un moment donné ce processus
assez injuste atroce que tu veux exister
on va choisir quelqu'un si ce n'est pas
le public ses protagonistes
vous avez décidé
que celle qui sera éliminé la première
est dû qu en tournage c'était
intéressant parce qu'on l'attend on le
tourne dans toutes ses formes de
conditions là où vachement de temps très
télévisuelle quoi très très solennelle
et c'est très agréable de jouer le
suspense dans le faux suspense on va le
la solennité le cérémonial et ça c'est
très agréable à jouer des scènes qui
était très court dans le script et au
final qu'on a décidé pour le rendre le
plus réel possible de le vraiment de les
tourner en conditions du réel
vraiment la tante lui qui prend les
billets qu'ils aient choisi
[Musique]
ils sont s'être ému stressé avoir peur
de perdre donc être soit hyper
revancharde soit être dans la rancune
soit être hyper émotif donc c'est
vraiment là où notre personnage est plus
à fleur de peau donc c'est forcément là
où c'est le plus drôle
on est vraiment des temps très long on
se regarde il ya beaucoup de silence et
tout ça et c'est vrai silence qu'il soit
dans lesquels messe des trucs assez
marrant vous le savez je crois que les
plus gros font rage qu'on a eu en tout
cas moi c'était pendant des cérémonies
franchement honnêtement ce tournage a
donc je rentre chez moi et je dirais mon
père mais je suis payé à rigoler c'est
honteux je devrais même pas le dire mais
c'est ce qui se passe quand être
florence qui jouait en aveugle qui parle
de cliquer comme ça quand marque
s'adresse à elle leïla qui m'angoisse à
hurler puisqu'elle jours une folle avec
sandra géraldine qui met des mains
pendant toute la cérémonie parce qu'elle
est venue que pour attraper des femmes
et sont très copines très très j'ai
passé la première semaine a
effectivement mettre des mains peu
j'avais vraiment les mains baladeuses et
à m'excuser est vraiment semaine deux je
me suis plus jamais excusé
[Musique]
si park on écourte je suis content sarah
un homme de la production est venu voir
moody's ait une vie et non pas que vit
la personne n'a dit que j'étais
totalement il l'être est tu veux dire
homme de lettres c'était un moment de
création énorme ce qui est plein de
vannes puis mettre plein de vannes à
chaque fois parce qu'avec certains
personnages qui n'est pas spécialement
de ré pigments dans les séquences est là
à chacune d'elles une réplique une vanne
esterra au ban du coup on voit la
physique la marque de chansons la préfon
la joue ça nous amuse tout de nous voir
passer nous voir jouer
pierre menez quand il faut la refaire
puis à refaire plus à refaire le plein
faire ce qu'on a comme 13
c'est un enfer quand même c'était
déplacé commencé quand chaque cérémonie
enfin chaque que prisent duré à peu près
25 minutes une demi heure quoi les vrais
cérémonie d'aidé à des roses dans le beh
temps américain il tourne quasiment
[Musique]
12h02 en temps réel cette les meufs
c'est pour ça il faut exprès parce que
les nanas du coup elles sont elles sont
à fleur de peau et les larmes à ça parce
qu'il ya sont vraiment elles sont deux
boucles sur les talons de 12 cm dans les
robes fourons ça commence à devenir
extrêmement long c'était genre c'était
vraiment éprouvant quoi donc on était à
chaque fois dans un tube border
d'émotion la deuxième personne à qui je
vais tendre ce billet c'est vrai que
c'est assez long en fait et même parfois
un peu laborieux parce que on reste on
refait reste debout très longtemps ses
valets et en même temps il ya un truc de
c'est pas un truc de vérité merci marc
tu as aussi ma prière mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'y croit vraiment on a eu
l'impression d'être sincèrement dans
l'émission dire que j'ai eu l'impression
de vivre la cérémonie en vrai comme on
est à tout le temps de trois caméras sur
nous on ne sait pas quand on est son
rhum sur nous donc il faut vraiment
jamais sortir de ça on s'est dit ça
tousse on s'est dit ah on a eu
l'impression tout d'un coup qu'on était
plus dans la fiction pure mais dans une
vraie véritable téléréalité on sait
qu'on se demandait même qui jonathan
cohen allait choisir entre d'aurea
tillier ana girardot ou moi la première
cérémonie qu'on a tourné
j'avais vraiment doria vers al din et
anna en face d'eux ils croient qu'ils
jouaient très bien le stress de
l'éviction jonathan qui était là
vraiment le décor tous aller les blues
il est rose et ça on est à toi de
ressentir vraiment ce que les gens
ressentent en faisant cela soit quand on
a fait couper ont fait à gardonne à fait
moi je lis c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
voilà la ville a été euphorique péter
tout le monde le plateau les comédiennes
on s'est tous dit que c'était l'équipe
ultime des jo issia on se disait en fait
on a fait ce métier exactement pour ça
et ça ça ça aviv pour des acteurs c'est
c'est le graal on rêve tous de se
confondre avec la situation on rêve tous
d'être nos personnages les pieds à la
tête
et alors ça arrive rarement dans le
métier quand ça arrive waouh c'est
complètement dingue c'est une récompense
là c'était là d'où cette scène ça m'a
vraiment mis dedans en fait je suis
vraiment le premier moment je me suis
pas vraiment on est en train de faire
une parodie du bachelor celle qui ouvre
le bal des éliminations
c'est vous orchidées non l'idée quand
elle se fait éliminer elvis a vraiment
comme une haute trahison de la part de
toutes ses filles elle sait que marc qui
est pas pour grand chose mais de la part
des donneurs alors on veut beaucoup
alors voila voila je suis bien content
de ne pas avoir ça elle m'a fait
confiance à toute cette jolie bande qui
lui ont tourné le dos dès le premier
épisode quoi et ça a été très dur pour
orchidées mais avec la vertu la grande
vertu de se dire que l'amour vaincra
elle s'est pas trompé marc sachent une
chose c'est que ma flamme sera
éternellement allumé pour toi
ça c'est clair c'est pas bien ce que
vous avez fait c'est pas bien
embrassement on dire au revoir